Olá você pode não ser fumante pensar que
por isso não está em risco desenvolver
doença pulmonar crônica mas é
fundamental que você Assista esse vídeo
porque ele traz um alerta aqui o Dr Alan
Machado Dutra médico h mais de 25 anos e
a resposta é sim você pode estar em
risco de doença pulmonar grave e crônica
devido ao uso de produtos de limpeza que
utiliza na sua casa e principalmente
pela forma como você usa eu estou
falando de desinfetantes alvejantes a
base de cloro água sanitária e aqueles
ácidos de limpar banheiro Olha que
assustador estudos mostraram que pessoas
que trabalham com limpeza profissional
podem sofrer danos nos pulmões
equivalentes aos danos de fumar 20
cigarros por dia durante mais de 10 anos
Isso significa que após 10 anos
trabalhando como profissional da limpeza
você pode ter o mesmo risco pulmonar que
um F antic crônico mas os riscos não são
exclusivos para os profissionais da
limpeza diaristas ou faxineiros
pesquisas indicam que apenas usar esses
produtos uma vez por semana já pode ser
suficiente para causar danos aos pulmões
Esse é um tema muito delicado e também
muito importante e eu quero que você
assista reflita compartilhe também esse
vídeo com o máximo de pessoas possível é
essencial que todos entendam os riscos
dos produtos de limpeza os perigos na
forma e quantidade que você utiliza os
riscos de misturar certos produtos de
limpeza aquela misturinha que você faz
em casa porque ela pode liberar gases
tóxicos devido às reações químicas e
isso pode prejudicar seriamente a sua
saúde e aos poucos Além disso usar
certos produtos em grandes quantidades
ou de forma inadequada pode ser muito
sério então fica comigo preste atenção
vamos entender juntos como podemos
proteger a nossa saúde e nossa família
eu sei que citar um estudo que liga o
risco de utilizar produtos de limpeza
aos danos pulmonares do cigarro pode ter
feito você ficar assustado e pensativo e
até reativo mas eu quero te dar uma
ideia mais clara disso sem entrar em
muitos detalhes técnicos para que o
vídeo não fique chato existem vários
estudos publicados revisados por pares
que descrevem como os produtos de
limpeza podem prejudicar nossa saúde
esses estudos que eu vou deixar na
descrição do vídeo mostram associação
entre os produtos de limpeza e uma série
de problemas de saúde um estudo em
particular acompanhou mais de 55.000
Enfermeiros por 8 anos que não tinham
doença pulmonar e uma boa parte deles
foram diagnosticados posteriormente com
a fma crônica eles descobriram que o uso
de desinfetantes em água sanitá
apenas uma vez por semana aumentava
muito o risco de desenvolver doenças
pulmonares mesmo considerando fatores
como idade peso tabagismo atividade
física Então pessoal fique o alerta para
vocês mas aqueles que limpam com mais
frequência como mencionei no início
podem sofrer danos pulmonares
equivalentes ao de fumar 20 cigarros por
dia além disso o dano não se restr ao
sistema respiratório ele pode afetar o
sistema imunológico nosso sistema de
defesa por causa da inflamação crônica
desencadeada por esses produtos de
limpeza então eles também causam
dermatites alergias cites e asma
especialmente em crianças há uma
associação entre o uso de produtos de
limpeza e o aumento de casos de asma
doenças autoimunes e até câncer então é
muito importante estar conscientes dos
riscos que Estamos correndo com os
produtos que usamos diariamente em
nossas casas recentemente atendi uma
paciente que foi diagnosticada com
doença pulmonar obstrutiva crônica o
chamado DPOC e para vocês entenderem
rapidamente o DPC é um termo médico que
abrange várias doenças pulmonares
progressivas como enfisema bronquite
crônica asma crônica e reversível e
algumas formas de
bronquiectasia cada uma dessas condições
é caracterizada por uma dificuldade em
respirar ou recuperar o fôlego os
sintomas podem incluir chiado no peito
tosse uma aperto no peito falta de ar
frequente e às vezes esses sinais são
erroneamente associados ao
envelhecimento Muitas pessoas acreditam
que é normal idosos tcem mais ou
sentirem falta de ar Mas isso não é
verdade esses sintomas não são normais
da idade avançada mas sim indicadores de
doenças progressivas que podem afetar
drasticamente a sua vida e até levar à
morte embora o tabagismo seja a
principal causa após o tabagismo e o
fumo passivo a exposição a produtos
químicos é um fator significativo
voltando à minha paciente ela nunca foi
fumante nunca conviveu com fumantes não
havia histórico de doença pulmonar na
família mesmo assim ela começou a sentir
sintomas e a sofrer com essa doença
durante a consulta descobri que ela
trabalhou como diarista por alguns anos
conversando com ela com conendo sua
história ela me contou que nunca se
preocupou com os produtos de limpeza que
usava nunca leu os rótulos nunca
considerou a quantidade certa ou que
esses produtos poderiam ser perigosos
ela relatou um episódio específico em
que passou muito mal e teve que se
afastar se ausentar do trabalho por
algum tempo porque teve uma pneumonia
química esse tipo de pneumonia ocorre
quando uma pessoa inala ou aspira
material que é tóxico para os pulmões
e ela teve isso após usar muita água
sanitária para lavar um banheiro desde
então a saúde dela nunca mais foi a
mesma Esse é um caso típico em que a
exposição contínua e sem cuidados a
esses produtos foi agravando a situação
da Minha paciente a água sanitária por
exemplo está associada a várias doenças
pulmonares distúrbios no sistema nervoso
queimaduras e como mencionei pneumonia
química para piorar ainda mais misturar
água sanitária com outros produtos de
limpeza pode produzir gases tóxicos que
dependendo da quantidade podem ser até
Mortais eu quero deixar claro que eu não
estou dizendo para ninguém deixar de
limpar a casa o que precisamos é
entender que podemos e devemos limpar
nossos ambientes mas sempre com cuidado
utilizando os produtos de maneira
correta e evitando excessos ler os
rótulos seguir as orientações é
fundamental apenas porque esses produtos
são vendidos livremente nos mercados não
significa que podemos usá-los de forma
indiscriminada também a forma como
utilizamos esses produtos pode ser muito
danosa pra saúde às vezes colocamos um
pouco de um produto um pouco de outro
fazer uma misturinha achando que vai dar
certo vai ser mais eficaz e limpar tudo
melhor isso pode criar o que podemos
chamar de sopa química perigosa ainda
mais perigosa do que usar os produtos
originais comprados muitos desses
produtos químicos nunca devem ser
misturados mas pouca gente sabe disso
por isso esse vídeo é tão importante por
exemplo misturar água sanitária com
qualquer produto a base de amônia produz
um gás tóxico chamado cloramina a
exposição esse gás pode provocar dor no
peito respiração ofegante falta de ar e
até pneumonia química mesmo que você não
sinta os sintomas de forma imediata a
exposição prolongada pode ser
extremamente Perigosa a amônia pode ser
encontrada em produtos de limpeza como
limpadores de vidro desinfetantes de
piso e até em produtos utilizados para
limpeza pós pintura então é fundamental
ler os rótulos Mas saiba que mesmo sem
estar indicado no rótulo amônia pode
estar presente no produto por isso evite
misturas que você desconheça os efeitos
a combinação de alvejante com qualquer
limpador a base deo produz gás cloro que
é extremamente perigoso mesmo níveis
baixos de Exposição durante um curto
período podem resultar irritação nos
olhos nariz e garganta Exposições mais
prolongadas ou em níveis mais altos
podem causar dor no peito vômitos
dificuldade respiratória e pneumonia
química os limpadores de ralo limpadoras
de forno e produtos para vasos sanitário
são considerados especialmente perigosos
porque contém ácidos no rótulo você verá
avisos como perigo e corrosivo esses
produtos corrosivos podem causar
queimaduras graves na pele também nos
olhos e se inalados ou ingeridos também
podem causar queimaduras
internas portanto Não misture produtos
corrosivos com outros produtos pois isso
Pode emitir vapores tóxicos extremamente
perigosos até mesmo vinagre que é um
ácido suave não deve ser misturado com
água sanitária pois pode resultar em
queimaduras químicas nos óleos e pulmões
produtos à base de ácido como limpadores
de ralo e de vaso sanitário nunca devem
ser misturados com outros produtos
pessoal a água sanitária também reage
com produtos fortes para limpeza de
fornos com peróxido de hidrogênio e até
com inseticidas formando gases tóxicos
ou outro erro comum é misturar água
sanitária com álcool isopropílico o que
pode produzir gases que danificam o
sistema nervoso também óleos pulmões
rins e fígado guardem essas informações
e nunca façam essas misturas na dúvida
eu não faça mistura nenhuma bom acho que
o alerta Ficou bem claro para vocês eu
quero que vocês comentem se já tiver
alguma experiência com produtos de
limpeza se conhece alguém que utiliza
esses produtos e teve problemas
pulmonares ou em outros órgãos asma
rinite alergias agora você pode estar se
perguntando já entendi o risco Estou
preocupado ou preocupada mas como manter
minha casa limpa o que que eu posso
fazer então por que que você complicou
minha vida Doutor Então vamos lá pessoal
primeira coisa sempre que for limpar a
casa e utilizar produtos como água
sanitária desinfetantes ou produtos
ácidos deixe o ambiente o mais arejado
possível abre as janelas abre as portas
deixe ventilar bem a tua casa nunca
limpe um banheiro com a janela ou Porta
Fechada sempre mantenha a ventilação
adequada muita gente vai limpar o
banheiro e fecha a porta e nunca faça
isso por favor segundo passo utilize os
equipamentos de proteção adequados use
luvas use máscara ao manipular produtos
mais fortes especialmente em ambientes
menores e menos ventilados a máscara
pode ajudar a reduzir a inalação de
gases ou gotículas desses produtos
embora em alguns casos a proteção
oferecida pela máscara possa não ser
suficiente infelizmente
terceiro sempre leia os rótulos do
produtos de limpeza siga as instruções
de uso e as quantidades que estão
recomendadas não exagere muita gente
acha que usar mais produto significa uma
limpeza mais eficiente Mas isso não é
verdade usar mais produto não garante a
limpeza apenas aumenta o desperdício e
os riscos pra saúde se o rótulo indica
que uma tampa de produto diluída em 1 l
de água é suficiente Siga essa instrução
pessoal já existe no mercado marcas de
produtos para limpeza que são mais
naturais que são biodegradáveis causam
menor risco de alergias e são menos
tóxicos O problema é que geralmente são
mais caros as marcas mais conhecidas por
aqui são bioz Green biowash Honda Eco
Garoa senite Além disso você pode usar
produtos feitos em casa que são mais
naturais existem várias dicas e você
pode procurar na internet como fazer o
seu próprio desinfetante em casa com
óleos essenciais por exemplo o óleo
essencial de melaleuca é excelente para
desinfetar e combater microorganismos
você também pode usar o vinagre desde
que Não misture com água sanitária o
vinagre pode ser utilizado na limpeza
geral e da cozinha outra alternativa é o
bicarbonato de sódio que pode ser
utilizado na limpeza de diversas
superfícies Então é isso Pessoal espero
que o alerta tenha ficado Claro não é
para ser terrorista é para ajudar vocês
mais uma vez eu não estou dizendo para
vocês não limparem as casas ou não
utilizarem produtos de limpeza mas sim
que é preciso ter muito cuidado com tudo
isso que eu mencionei Este é uma alera
importante eu peço que compartilhe esse
vídeo que mais pessoas saibam desse
assunto que não é com com frequência
possa entender evitar esses
perigos
os a vida de alguém pode mudar também no
[Música]
canal Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração e
você é Vera